[Music]
French president Emmanuel macron spent
three days with President Trump last
week while German Chancellor Angela
Merkel got only three hours
let's get insight into what's really
going on and welcome the newly confirmed
US ambassador to Germany I never thought
I'd say that Rick Rick Grinnell from Los
Angeles are you doing I'd I'd have a
Stein of beer to tea to toast you but I
guess I can't do that on national TV how
you doing you're feeling good I'm
feeling great and the most important
part is today I am four-and-a-half years
cancer-free coming up on five years so I
just got that diagnosis today that tweet
you and I are thrivers cancer thrivers
so I was so happy to see that's right
Rick and I have only known each other
for 25 years full disclosure we
shouldn't say how long Rick but a long
time and I was like seven though yeah
you're basically in utero still so let's
talk about a bunch of things I want to
talk about merkel with with trump but i
have to play something for you because I
hadn't heard this at this soundbite
until we were getting ready for our show
this was Menendez senator Menendez
before your confirmation vote let's
watch mister Grinnell's derogatory
comments about women are simply
unacceptable for anyone to make in
public let alone a diplomat and I would
go further not only do these tweets show
bad judgment they show us who mr.
Grinnell really is and how comfortable
he is publicly contributing his own
brand of toxic political discourse will
he do such things if he's confirmed and
goes to Germany will he insult via his
Twitter account the female Chancellor of
Germany
I write Rick I've gotta say this was one
among with Bob Menendez his past that
was one of the most hilarious moments
that's how desperate the devil because
what you sent out a you know a snarky
tweet Oh five years I don't even know
what it was about but how did you react
to that look I I haven't met senator
Menendez
I've never met him he doesn't know me I
have reached out to him since
confirmation to ask for a meeting I'd
love to meet him I'd love to talk to him
about Germany I'd love to have him see
who I am and see that actually what he
said on the floor is wrong but I'm gonna
keep on and try to have that meeting I
think once people get to know me they
see that that you're already a diplomat
look at you you're so diplomatic
obviously at the UN as as the the press
at to say at the UN the United States
but let's talk now about what happened
last week with Merkel for our viewers
who aren't all that you know into the EU
politics and where she is versus McCrone
why did that seem a little bit
uncomfortable I said last week she
looked like she had eaten some bad
schnitzel which is not diplomatic at all
of me to say but that's why I'm not an
ambassador you know I don't have to say
I have to say that watching Chancellor
Merkel and president Trump negotiate
they clearly like each other they
clearly know each other but every
American would be incredibly proud to
see how Donald Trump negotiates I've
spent years watching presidents and
secretaries of state really talk when
they're in one-on-one meetings about
moral arguments when it comes to foreign
policy what should be done and we don't
have just a pure moral argument from the
president we have multi-pronged
arguments and I've longed for the day to
have a president who actually negotiates
with all of America's strengths our
economic strengths our agricultural
strengths our tariffs all of the issues
that we bring to the table need to be
brought to the table in order to
pressure the relationship for a better
you know jobs record for for more jobs
for Americans for trade that expands and
President Trump is really good at it and
so I think what you saw any American who
would see them negotiating would feel
very comfortable she looked
uncomfortable I'm sorry it's okay that
she looked really uncomfortable to me I
mean she did not look like Mike I think
they're kind of slapping each other on
the back but maybe she was just wanted
to spend more time with him I don't know
I I have to say when they were
negotiating together and
where they were across the table they
were not uncomfortable okay clearly have
a great friendship but they have some
differences okay well that's fine one
thing that I find fun is to read these
so-called foreign policy experts in
Europe about what they think about Trump
because they don't understand them or
they're concerned about them this is the
12 German x experts an op-ed about Trump
this is from October last year the
liberal world order with its foundation
and multilateralism its global norms and
values it's open societies and markets
is in danger Donald Trump is the first
US president since World War two to
fundamentally question the ideas in
institutions of the liberal
international order and Rick I would say
about that yes he is and yes he's right
because America needs to focus on
keeping herself strong and helping her
allies but the multilateralism you know
sometimes only goes so far
well I think you know when you look back
and you see candidate Donald Trump in
the election he was very clear about
what tax payers were getting and what
they were tired of paying for because
they don't always get the return that
they expected I mean you look at the
agencies multilateral agencies like the
UN or NATO and we have paid a
significant amount and I think it's a
it's a right question to say are we
getting enough is there enough US
leadership and that's exactly what
President Trump brought to the table
with with Angela Merkel but I do have to
say this Laura they when it was all done
when we were all finished with the press
conference the president took the
Chancellor up to the residence with the
vice president and myself and gave a
personal tour of the vice president of
the the residence the presidential
residence at the White House that was
the first time that's not if the
Chancellor had been up there it was
shocking to hear that she had never been
able to see the Lincoln Bedroom never
been able to see the Gettysburg Address
and President Trump took her there yeah
well you know he he wants to put on the
charm offensive he's really good at it
you know we've told them the charm charm
was very good at it tough but charm
Rick Rennell congratulations will will
be taught
continuously for sure or in Germany